you've never had a near-death experience
for like two weeks yeah when Warren
Zevon was dying I think David Letterman
asked him what you know is there any
message in this you know that you're
about to die you've had this incredible
Canon of songs that you've written and
performed is there any lesson and
Warren's even said enjoy every sandwich
and it says deadly serious point which
is you don't appreciate the sheer Joy Of
Being Alive because you can't it reminds
me of in New Orleans when Katrina hit
and I remember somebody on TV saying who
could possibly imagine that the Levee
would break and I thought didn't Led
Zeppelin sing a song called what they do
yeah I mean it's just I don't understand
it but I've come to accept that most
humans cannot live with abstract
knowledge if something hasn't happened
in 20 years it's not it's not going to
happen if it's never happened and you
never need to worry about anything
that's a low probability doesn't need to
be thought about in the context exactly
right